les propositions des professionnels du
btp sont regroupés en cinq grands
chapitres d'abord construire une
dynamique
cela passe par un déblocage du ter trop
de terres gelées empêche une
mobilisation du foncier les délais
administratifs trop longs sont un frein
au développement des projets ensuite les
logements sociaux il faudrait en
construire 1200 contre six actuellement
autre secteur porteur pour le btp le
tourisme le développement du spirit
tourisme est vue d'un bon oeil par la
profession qui espère bénéficier des
retombées
elle préconise aussi la construction de
8000 nouvelles chambres d'hôtel qui
permettrait d'atteindre la barre des
2000 chambres et ainsi faire de la
martinique une destination touristique
majeure
troisième grand chapitre la sûreté il
s'agit pour la profession de faire
reconnaître son expertise en matière de
construction parasismique et para
cyclonique
d'autre part pour les acteurs du btp les
primordial de lancer un plan haute
d'urgence il s'agit de remettre normes
toutes les infrastructures
d'approvisionnement et d'assainissement
les deux derniers points construire
tropicale et construire l'avenir
s'inscrivent dans le long terme où il
faudra tenter d'anticiper les
catastrophes naturelles développer la
mobilité sur le territoire du nord au
sud de lille ou encore réussir la
transition énergétique
un livre gris destiné aux élus et à
l'état pur clairement dire que la
relance de l'activité du btp passe par
une politique de projets structurants
pour les 20 prochaines années